so a radical republican trump is
congressman madison cawthorn who knows
nothing about history nothing about
foreign policy nothing about geopolitics
nothing about economics nothing about
mathematics nothing okay you get it um
he has been taking the
also very friendly to russia approach
of just criticizing ukraine but
criticizing ukraine for things which
really russia can be more heavily
criticized for including a lack of
democracy and so on and so forth and
this is just beyond parody madison
cawthorne did some kind of a public
event
and someone in the audience said
they wanted to know more about what's
really going on in russia and ukraine
and hilariously they want madison to
explain it to them which is just so
funny like why on earth would you go to
him but let's take a look at the clip
and see him trot out even more extreme
versions of the same talking points
anybody else
yeah congressman yes sir
we got this mess in the
eastern europe there with ukraine and
all that i know you've made some
reference to uh
president zielinski being a thug or
being
in the government being corrupt
we're all i think we're all trying to
figure this thing out i mean
it seems like we're on the precipice of
a could be a possible major disaster can
you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we stand with that now before
we even hear the answer
dude this madison cothran doesn't know
anything this guy looks like he's you
know 55 60 65 i don't know um
how ignorant is he
that to find out what's going on with
geopolitics
he goes to an event with a a clueless
congressman
and asks him tell me what's really going
on okay i will so one as i was saying
earlier
there's so much propaganda coming out on
all sides of this boat from russia from
ukraine from a lot of other countries
involved from our own media
that things are becoming so murky and
hard to understand but so that's also a
really popular talking point they use
it's just so complicated that ufc guy
bryce mitchell also did it
we don't know what's going on it's crazy
before we all jump to conclusions thing
we're going to go defend a democracy in
eastern europe we have to realize that
there is
the ukrainian government is so well
known for corruption now remember the
russian government is more well known
for corruption and russia still invaded
ukraine uh there's only it's one of the
major sex trafficking hubs of the entire
world
russia is also a major sex traffic
trafficking hub of the world and it
doesn't justify the russian invasion of
ukraine
that area the ukrainian people are
wonderful people there's a lot of really
great people and those who are
patriotically fighting for their freedom
i commend them they're doing great um
but this is not a country that you know
i i feel like is the shining beacon of
what really truly is the standard of a
good and clean and uh transparent
government and russia is even less a
standard of good and clean and
transparent government on any freedom
and democracy index ukraine ranks far
higher than russia but
either way
russia invaded ukraine so it's it's not
only is he
ignoring russia's record
he's ignoring that none of it would
justify an invasion anyway
and so there was a lot of corruption
that's been there you know in 2014 there
was basically a regime change that
happened uh you know there's there's
just a lot of questions and questionable
issues going on there i i do plan on
releasing in detail in a few weeks just
kind of something with some ideas and
some thoughts imagine waiting around for
madison kawthorne's report with ideas
okay so beyond parody here's a bonus
clip madison cawthorne in the context of
all of this strife
he mentions the bible but he doesn't
even know what he's talking about when
he mentions the bible
they would be easy to get
disheartened with the things going on
not only in our country but in our world
today uh their war is breaking out you
know in revelation we're talking about
there will be wars and rumors of wars i
think that's exactly what we're seeing
so not number one i don't know what the
hell the bible has to do with any of
this but his references are also
incorrect wars and rumors of wars is
from mark and from matthew i mean i
don't even care about this stuff but he
just happens to be wrong
in mark 13 5
jesus said to them watch out that no one
deceives you many will come in my name
claiming i am he and will deceive many
when you hear of wars and rumors of wars
do not be alarmed matthew 24 4 jesus
answered watch out that no one deceives
you
for many will come in my name claiming i
am the messiah and will deceive many you
will hear of wars and rumors of wars but
see to it that you are not alarmed do
they even care
that the bible stuff he's quoting isn't
accurate does anything matter at this
point
when people are going and asking madison
cawthorne for his view on geopolitics my
instinct is the facts don't matter we'll
have these clips on our instagram at
david pakman show it is a brand new year
maybe you have goals around getting in
better shape maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our
longtime sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto
or if like me you just try to limit your
sugar intake you can build your own
variety pack with flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cinnamon
cookies and cream waffle maple blueberry
that's my favorite magic spoon lets you
enjoy a sweet delicious snack without
the guilt you can stick to your goals
and still treat yourself and if you
don't love magic spoon as much as i do
they'll give you all of your money back
no questions asked magic spoon is giving
my audience five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman